>>Christopher Pagan: We're going to
be taking a short survey again today
to see how we're all doing.
>>Janice Lombardi: At Garza,
the students can voice concerns
that they may have about their learning.
Student surveys have a dramatic
impact on their ownership
of learning, and on teachers' practice.
>>It's so important for
students to have a voice,
particularly in challenging subjects,
where it's difficult to take a risk
and say, "You know, I
don't really know one thing
that you've just said in Physics."
>>Kenya: By them asking for our
feedback, it kind of makes you feel
like you have a voice, you know?
Kind of makes you feel
a little bit important.
>>Christopher Pagan: I was looking at my
students performance in my Physics class
and found that they just weren't
performing up to my expectations.
So I developed a simple survey that
asked the students a few questions on,
you know, "Why do you turn
in your homework late?
Or why do you always
turn it in on time?"
>>Kenya: Do we like the way he teaches?
Do we like the way he
demonstrates examples?
Are we satisfied with our
performance in that class?
That was basically the purpose of the
survey, so he can know what to improve.
>>Christopher Pagan: You can put
your name on it if you want to.
If you don't want to, you don't have to.
And remember, be honest!
All right?
If you're not honest,
we can't make changes
and we don't know how
to make adjustments.
>>Janice Lombardi: He
got the information back,
and those student surveys changed
and informed his instruction.
>>Christopher Pagan: Some of the
students they were very strong
in the math, they wanted a little bit
more help gaining the conceptual ideas
and so I started to implement more
hands-on activities with the students.
>>So what you're going to be doing is
trying to use the principle of resonance
to calculate the speed of sound.
>>Student: And so what we're
doing is we're recording the data.
See how the tuning fork is 384 hertz,
and we measured the tube diameter,
which was 1.8 meters, and
we measured the length
of the tube, which was 14.6 meters.
>>Christopher Pagan: I
give them extra practice
with homework problems, or pre-quizzes.
And so it helps the students
boost their grades
and I think it gives them
more confidence, as well.
>>Kenya: I feel like I have
been learning more and kind
of getting the subject more.
>>Janice Lombardi: So this year, we
did a student survey for all teachers.
And we asked things like, "Do you
feel comfortable in this class?
Do you trust the teacher?
Do I feel like I'm challenged?"
And we got lots of meaningful feedback.
>>Cynthia Hess: One of the things that
I really took away from the surveys,
my students needed something different
from me than what they were getting.
Come on in, guys.
They were ready for something more
rigorous, and some of the answers were,
"I wish she didn't feel she had to
hold our hands through tough things."
That was really enlightening.
In terms of how it affected my teaching
practice, instead of reading something
with them in class, and then guiding
them through and telling them what
to look for, I might give them
something to read outside of class,
and they would tell me what they found.
>>Student: I think what she meant like
the color of the bags was like the skin
of the people, and the stuff
inside was like your personality,
what we've been through and all that.
>>Cynthia Hess: Experience, good!
>>Christopher Pagan: Though
we're all resistant to change,
teaching has to be something
that's fluid.
We always have to be
adapting to our students.
>>Janice Lombardi: I think this
process of getting the student voice,
and acting upon the student
voice, actually builds their faith
in the system here of learning,
as they become more empowered,
they are more successful.
>>Student: So there's a type of
language that was in the story.
>>Cynthia Hess: Good!
Anybody else want to share
their thoughts or opinions?